in 2018 an original horror film from a
guy best known for starring in the
office premiered and much like the
murderous creatures that part of the
story the buzz quickly spread it wasn't
long before we learned that a quiet
place part two was on the way here's
what we know so far the world of a quiet
place is a whole world despite the
relative isolation of the main
characters at the part of the first film
we only see this strange apocalypse and
the creatures which caused it through
the lens of the Abbott family whose
lives largely revolve around their rural
home and brief trips into nearby towns
to search for supplies we rarely glimpse
other survivors in the film and when we
do they're brief and brutal reminding us
that it's very difficult to stay alive
in this world while the sequel will
expand upon the relatively small scale
of the first film the Abbott family will
remain its focus Emily Blunt Millicent
Simmons and Noah jube will all be back
as Evelyn Regan and Marcus respectively
so if you're eager to see what life is
like for the Abbott's now you're going
to get your wish a quiet place roots its
story in a very personal way offering
very few glimpses of the rest of the
world there is a sense of a larger world
at work beyond the first film single
family story though and unsurprisingly
the second film is going to explore that
writer director John Krasinski explained
the thing that I loved in the movie
where my mind kept wandering as we were
making it was the question of who was on
the other end of those fires when the
father lights the fire and in the
distance those other fires light up how
do those people survive how did that old
man survive that means that in addition
to returning stars who will reprise
their roles as the Abbott's a quiet
place part 2 will feature several new
faces Gillian Murphy and Djimon Hounsou
among others are signed on to play other
survivors in the newly expanded world a
quiet place was John Krasinski's first
for effort at the helm but he did much
more than sit in the director's chair
Paul writers Brian woods and Scott Beck
are credited with the original story for
the film Krasinski also earned writing
credits on the first movie after
stepping in to rewrite back in Woods
original script that made his stamp on
the project even more personal something
is carrying over in a big way for the
second installment this time around
presents gives both the director and the
sole credited writer with becken Woods
credited only as the
creators of the characters from the
original film a quiet place left the
Abbott family in a precarious but
promising situation in its final minutes
with their soundproof barn basement
flooded Evelyn's caring for a new baby
and older children Regan and Marcus
trying to escape one of the creatures
the Abbott made the ultimate sacrifice
for his family allow any creature to
kill him so the kids could reunite with
their mother after the reunion Regan and
Evelyn were able to kill the creature
when Regan realized she could amplify
the feedback her cochlear implant was
emitting when the creatures were near
causing it to spasm and creating an
opening kill it
the sequel will presumably present an
opportunity for the abbot's to share
their newfound skills with the rest of
the world provided they can find more
humans plus if the cochlear implants can
take the creatures down what else can we
could be looking at a film that finds
some very inventive new ways to
weaponize sound both as a monster slain
weapon and as a moviemaking tool one of
the great appeals of a quiet place is
its ability to captivate while only
telling us what we need to know to
follow the story and the rules of the
world as a result we have very little
confirmed information about the things
that make the earth a quiet place the
creatures we know that they are
extraterrestrial and their origin and
the film tells us that they were able to
effectively wipe out most humans and a
number of other animals on earth in a
matter of months driving the survivors
into hiding we know that they have
incredibly sensitive hearing that allows
them to sense nearly any sound from some
distance away that their skin is armored
and that sounds above a certain register
caused them to become disoriented and
exposed vulnerable parts of their body
offering an avenue by which to kill them
so well uh quiet plays part to keep
these rules and only these rules in
place or will we learn more about these
mysterious beings the answer may lie in
one particular revelation from the first
a quiet place press to earth at one
point it could have been a Cloverfield
movie according to the original
screenwriters while they were still in
the script stages of developing the
first film there was an idea that
perhaps the creatures at the heart of it
could be tied to the same ones within
the Cloverfield universe beckon would
noted that Paramount Pictures ultimately
saw their film as quote a totally
different movie but the possibility was
there and that raises an interesting
question if a quiet place part 2 hits as
big as its predecessor did what comes
next
is it possible that this film's universe
could expand to be a part of something
bigger but a crossover still happen it
seems unlikely but at the very least
it's amusing to think about the first
full trailer for a quiet place part 2
arrived on New Year's Day 2020 and
revealed some of what's next for the
Abbott family as they venture out beyond
their farmhouse beyond that though it
took us all the way back to the first
day of the end of the world and showed
us a harrowing sequence in which Evelyn
is trying to drive her children through
a
in neighborhood is the world descends
into chaos back in the present the
abbot's are heading out into the world
with Evelyn's new baby who's largely
confined to a box with an oxygen mask
and tank hooked up to it Evelyn Regan
and Marcus stumble upon Emmet who
doesn't seem at all happy to see them as
Emily argues that there are still people
out in the world that are worth saving a
series of chilling visuals hint that she
may be wrong it's an intriguing the real
monsters are among us set up and we
can't wait to see where it goes next a
quiet place part 2 hits theaters March
20th 2020 very nearly two years to the
day after the first film's debut in 2018
some sequels may take years to fall into
place but we won't have to wait too much
longer to see this one check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]